from Colts Campion Rappaport joining me
are on the show how are you in what's
happened to rich how are you I'm doing
fine so anybody freaked out there or
they're listening to Andrew Luck saying
don't freak out
is there any freaking out okay um first
of all just so we're clear I am not
freaking out okay
I am very right you saw it you so relax
oh yeah well of course it's most casual
thing ever except for just trying to
catch 12 different planes in 12 days
I'm actually legitimately surprised at
the lack of freaking out here I mean
think of the things that the cults have
not done they have not seen the
franchise quarterback practice did not
seen him as far as I know throw football
they have not signed a veteran backup
quarterback or someone besides Scott
tolsey who is a capable backup but you
know is not sort of one of the bigger
names stopgap guys and when I've talked
to Colts coaches and personnel people as
I've done everyone kind of says yeah
when he's ready he'll be ready he's okay
long-term he's great he's at no setback
so that's cool but um they are very very
relaxed about a starting quarterback who
has not been out of practice - Wow
what is Luck had to say if you come
across him at all there's he is he out
of sight out of mind what's going on
there he has not been in sight he spoke
to media members you know a couple days
ago but I have not put eyes on him
Judy batiste I know talk to him chitchat
yesterday he was in very good spirits
and very happy putting on some weight
and you know rehabbing and kind of
getting some some things back to where
they need to be but he's not he's not
out watching practice he's not sort of
the eye
hanging over the team they don't want
him on the field just kind of watching
which I thought was interesting not like
shocking but just kind of interesting
you know usually guys just take the
mental reps I guess he's so smart that
he doesn't need it but he's been out of
sight and kind of out of mind a very
very odd thing here honestly which so
let's let's talk quarterbacks tenían off
this look
120 some odd quarterbacks are in camps
right now none of them named Colin
Kapernick why why because of all the
things that the Ravens have said
publicly and you know all the people
close to Colin Kaepernick have all said
the same thing you know it's a you know
it's all the things you've read
blackballing and the owners prevent to
him and all that and I didn't believe
any of it but then you hear and I don't
think black blowing is the right word
but it's obvious that the Ravens almost
have two decisions they have the
football decision you know and I think
there's a pretty solid argument that
Colin Kaepernick would help their
football team compete with Ryan Mallett
and maybe win that job and then you know
there's the other thing
there's a non football discussion
whatever blowback you're going to get
whatever community leaders or whatever
think whatever sponsors and ads people
think which is a little crazy and so
rarely enters the discussion that I
don't even know what to think about it
because you know there are teams who
have people who have been convicted of
crimes that are not good on their team
people who have you know served time I
mean the Vikings on the free-agent who
you know was under house arrest earlier
this offseason and they've all served
their time and and been remorseful and
you know going to come back as better
people
what did Conn Kaepernick do that he
needs to be remorseful for or
rehabilitated from he literally did
something that is in his rights as a
human as a citizen and it's almost like
everyone is asking him to deserve time
or something not I mean well I guess
he's in a way than serving time a house
in his house right I mean yeah so wait
agree what will have to happen for him I
don't see a path to him getting a job
barring some Teddy Bridgewater type
moment happening to a starting
quarterback around here in the NFL you
know Ryan Mallett has struggled at
practice and at some point and you know
it so it's always a sliding scale right
at some point the talent or the need
outweighs the distract
and although I hate that word or the
Oscar filled concerns even though I hate
data whatever you I don't even know what
to call it for colin kaepernick because
he's literally doing good in the world
as we speak but you know at some point
the football outweighs the other stuff
and it now continues to struggle and Joe
Flacco continues not beyond to not be on
the field someone on the Ravens will say
alright we feed this guy wish assignment
or about whatever else but absent the
Ravens it's going to take an injury it's
going to take a legitimate injury for
the right situation for the right team
with a system that he knows and is
familiar with it's going to take a lot
of things
Ian Rapoport joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show from Colts camp as we have
finally hit August 2017 Hall of Fame
game a couple of days away when we'll
all be there in Canton Ohio as part of
the NFL network's coverage of the Hall
of Fame who is going to be the rookie
quarterback to start week one there's
always one there's always one when you
don't expect it who do you think's got
the best shot boy okay so I think it's
going to be none right
so unlike most years I think it's going
to be none but let me answer it in the
quarterback who has the best chance yes
I'm starting week one on the static is
to Sean Watson you know Tom Savage is a
starter in Houston right now in West
Virginia but mostly in Houston and he's
good and he had some good practices and
he is the starter there's no competition
except that Watson has been great and
he's been he's worked incredibly well as
the first on the field every day he
takes copious notes he character wise he
is off the charts and they love him so
he's going to play in a lot of preseason
games early so we're going to see his
you know development right up front and
he has the best chance of forcing a team
to abandon whatever they plan to do
similar to what Russell Wilson did in
Seattle similar to what Blake bortles
did in Jacksonville being so impressive
compared to whatever else you have where
they go yeah I remember those plans we
talked about it yeah I plan to change
that well I'm wondering if we shouldn't
be
sleeping on Kaiser Fillion you know I
had I'm sorry I don't know where you are
are you see are you in the airport now
are you where are you well I'm right
here okay good
I yeah okay I'm good I can hear you now
no I'm saying that we shouldn't be
sleeping on Kaiser Ian what do you think
about that that he's you know yeah I
mean that's a great point and I when I
went in my head
that was not the one that I immediately
thought of and it's interesting to hear
the rave reviews that he that he's
gotten because you know there was a time
especially early on in Notre Dame season
when like we thought this guy was going
to be one of the top picks in the NFL my
gut there is it is Brock Osweiler or
Cody Kessler I know everyone rolls their
eyes at Brock but I really have heard
he's been impressive and I'm actually
heading out there in a couple days I'm
looking forward to seeing and look right
up front but I think I think Kaiser is
probably going to take more of a this
would be one of those code takes exposed
things but I think Kaiser is going to be
more of a wait-and-see dealing in in
Cleveland you know while Kessler and
Brock battle it out so where are you
headed next after Colts camp are you
going to Cleveland now so where'd you go
what' I'm going to go to the build first
in Rochester I'm gonna go check out a
garbage plate and meet some people there
we got the local cuisine which okay and
then I go to Cleveland and then I go to
Atlanta and then I go home for one day
then I head out west okay so you're not
a lot of them you're not kind of weird
laundry stops in Washington's along the
way but did a fun trip okay and what
what so what are you expecting last one
for you and what are you expecting to
see in western New York other than the
garbage plate what are you expecting to
see out of the out of the bills with you
know mcdermott now there and obviously
Tyrod Taylor not going anywhere
what what no Anthony Lin what what's
going on there would expect to see I
expected the tone to be very different
you know and I think there's been you
mean without rank sharp correct yeah and
like you know Victor
it is not a soft spoken in the media but
he's really kind of like a hard-nosed
dude but by comparison to Rex he feels
like a mouse you know but I'm curious to
see the tone there I think it's going to
be quieter and how much more organized
it is like Rex is a lot of things but
he's not the most detail-oriented person
so by the end it was a little bit of a
circus like talent-wise was actually
pretty I don't know Tugwell he was
obviously fired but like there are some
talent things that are pretty good there
like I think their actual rosters is
really competitive probably competitive
with a team like the dolphin so I'm
curious to see how strict and
disciplined and good they look on the
field compared to the level of last you
know Jets at Buffalo Bills week one
coming up in the National Football
League safe travels Ian Rapoport will
chat soon all right thanks for it next
Rizzo universe with the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy